oh hello all-stars hi dears queens are
back for their Redemption and this time
they're playing a brand new game all
star rules have been suspended
oh sorry robot what but in the web
there's a twist this year they threw out
the rule book and we've got lip-sync
assassins films lip-synch for their
legacy against a lip-sync assassin a
different superstar Queen
I need to know your honest reaction when
you learned that was happening
should we just give it to her yeah just
do one oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god what's happening oh my god what's
happening well this was mine what mine
mine mine in the trailer I'm just like
we're protesting against it yeah dang it
cuz you know before we went on we we
studied the previous seasons really okay
maybe I can figure out the trajectory of
where a moon's got to go for season five
good nope I think that homework for
nothing we always know the root ball is
gonna be shady somehow that's just drag
race 101 right there I was suspecting
the whole lipstick assassin thing is
intimidating but also that's what we do
for leaving and hello if we have to
lip-sync we gotta turn the party we know
that for sure and this girls in this
cast are not chickenhead honey these
girls are legends honey so I know we're
ready for a bottle this is season five
of Allstars I know it's gonna be just
great you know what I realized just now
is that we got a twist but we didn't
necessarily need one enough drama rise
out the twists for real girls
you called her a pig in a wig Pete and
everyone is
because we brought enough emotions and
feelings and fighting and all of these
girls came ready to fight for the crown
tooth and nails so yeah but the way that
was the least of our problem there is
one thing that I am kind of excited to
see and I'm gonna leave you with this
there may or may not have been a little
drama that we experienced and I think
that maybe watching the season we might
get to find out the truth because we
know I was never really resolved
resolved so I'm hoping that they catch
the behind the scenes so we can find out
the truth okay all I'm gonna say about
you have to tune in to find out what
happened I don't know we don't go I
don't know what she talking about either
and you don't know either Derek
[Music]